My fellow Americans.
When I ran for president,
I was told the days
of bipartisanship are over.
The Democrats, Republicans
can no longer work together.
But I refuse to believe that
because America
can never give in
to that way of thinking.
Look,
the only way
American democracy can function
is through compromise and consensus.
And that's what I worked to do
as your president,
you know, to forge bipartisan agreement
where it's possible
and where it's needed.
I've signed more than 350 bipartisan laws
thus far, and with two and a half years,
including a historic law
that rebuilding America
so that we can ranked
number one in the world
in infrastructure
instead of where we ranked
now number 13 in the world.
Another historic law
rebuilding our manufacturing base
so that will lead the world once again
in making semiconductor chips
so much more
and so so many more
and so many more sophisticated ones.
And now a bipartisan budget agreement.
This is vital because
it's because it's essential
to the progress
we made over the last few years
is keeping full faith and credit
of the United States of America
and passing a budget to continue
to grow our economy
and reflects our values as a nation.
That's why I'm speaking tonight to report
on the crisis averted
and what we're doing
to protect America's future.
Passing this budget agreement
was critical.
The stakes could not have been higher
if we had failed to reach an agreement
on the budget.
There were extreme
voices
threatening to take America
for the first time
in our 247 year history
and a default on our national debt.
Nothing,
nothing would have been
more irresponsible.
Nothing would have been
more catastrophic.
Our economy would have been thrown
into recession.
Retirement accounts
for millions of Americans would have
been decimated.
8 million Americans
would have lost their jobs.
The fault would have been have destroyed
our nation's credit rating,
which would have made everything
from mortgages
to car loans
to funding for the government
much more expensive
and would have taken years
to climb out of that hole.
And America's
standing as the most trusted,
reliable financial partner in the world
would have been shattered.
So it was critical to reach an agreement.
And it's very good news
for the American people.
No one got everything they wanted,
but the American people
got what they needed.
We averted an economic crisis
and economic collapse.
We're cutting spending
and bringing the deficits down
at the same time.
We're protecting important priorities
from Social Security
to Medicare to Medicaid
to veterans,
to our transformational investments
in infrastructure and clean energy.
I want to commend Senator
Speaker McCarthy.
You know, he and I,
we and our teams
were able to get along things done.
We were straightforward
to fund another completely honest
with a respectful with one another.
Both sides operated in good faith.
Both sides kept their word.
And I also want to commend
other congressional leaders.
House Minority Leader Jeffries,
Senate Majority Leader Schumer,
Senate Minority Leader McConnell.
They acted responsibly
and put the good of the country
ahead of politics.
A final vote in both chambers
was overwhelming
far more bipartisan
anyone thought was possible.
So I want to thank the members
of Congress
who voted to pass this agreement,
which I'm going to sign tomorrow.
Become the law.
So here's what the deal does.
First, it cuts spending,
and over the next ten years,
the deficit will be cut
by more than $1 trillion
and now be on top of the record,
1.7 trillion, $1.7 trillion.
I already cut the deficit in
my first two years in office.
And it's clear
we're all
on a much more fiscally responsible
course
than the one
I inherited when I took office
four years ago. When I came to office.
The deficit has increased every year
the previous four years
and nearly
$8 trillion
add to the national debt
in the last administration.
And now we're turning things around.
And that's good for America.
You know,
my dad used to have an expression.
He said, Joey,
don't tell me what you value.
Show me your budget.
I'll tell you what you value.
That's at the heart of this debate.
What do we value?
Protecting seniors.
You may remember during my State
of the Union address, there were spirit.
There was a spirited exchange between me
and a few Republicans
spontaneously occurring on the floor
of the House of Representatives.
I was pointing out that for years
some of them were
putting forward
proposals
to cut Social Security, Medicare,
and some of them and I took exception.
And they said very loudly
that that wasn't true.
So I asked them on the floor that night,
I said, ask them a simple question.
Will you agree not to cut Social Security
and Medicare? Nor
would they agree to protect
these essential programs,
a lifeline
for millions of Americans, programs
that these Americans
were paying
into every single paycheck they've earned
since they started working.
And that provides so much peace of mind
with the bright lights and cameras on
those three Republicans
who were protesting They agreed.
They said they wouldn't cut it.
That's how we protected
Social Security, Medicare
from the beginning
and from it being cut, period.
Health care was another priority for me,
a top priority.
I made it clear from the outset
I would not agree
to any cuts in Medicaid.
Another essential lifeline
for millions of Americans,
including children in poverty,
the elderly
and nursing homes and Americans
living with disabilities.
Original House
Republican proposal would have cut health
care for up
to 21 million Americans on Medicaid.
I said no,
Medicare is protected
and so
are millions of people most in need.
Look,
I have long believed
that the only one truly sacred obligation
that the government
has is to prepare
those we send into harm's way
and care for them
and their families when they come home,
when they don't come home.
That's why my last budget
provided VA hospitals
with additional funding
for more doctors, nurses and equipment
to accommodate
the needs of veterans
and more appointments.
The House Republican plan would have met
30 fewer million
VA health care visits for our veterans.
We didn't let that happen.
In addition,
this bill fully funds
the Bipartisan Pact Act,
the most significant law in decades
for veterans
exposed a toxic burn pits and for
their families.
Expands access to those veterans
and their families.
To health care
and to disability benefits.
Look, we're investing in American
and our people. And in our future,
we've created over 13 million new jobs.
Nearly 800,000 manufacturing jobs.
Where is it?
Britain and America
can't lead the world again
in manufacturing.
Unemployment is at 3.7%.
More Americans are working today
than ever in the history of this country.
And inflation
has dropped ten straight months in a row
in this debate.
I refuse to put what was responsible
for all this economic progress
on the chopping block.
This bipartisan agreement protects
the law
that will help us build
the best infrastructure in the world.
Fully protects the Chips and Science Act,
which is going to bring
key parts of our supply chain to America.
So don't rely on others
like semiconductors,
those tiny computer
chips smaller than the tip of your finger
that affect nearly everything
we rely on, from cell phones
to building automobiles.
The most sophisticated weapons system
and so much more.
We protected another law that
I passed and signed last year
that finally beat Big Pharma,
which I'm trying to do for over 30 years.
It finally gives Medicare
the power to negotiate lower drug prices,
just like the VA has been able
to do for veterans
This law has already dramatically
cut the cost of insulin for seniors
from as much as $400 a month to just $35
a month for insulin.
Negotiating lower drug prices
not only saves seniors a lot of money,
it saves the country a lot of money.
$160 billion.
It's not having to be paid out
because with
drug prices are more rational.
We pay the highest drug prices
of any industrial nation in the world,
and it's just the beginning.
You know,
we also protected
the most significant breakthrough
ever, ever
in dealing with existential threat
of climate change.
Today a new wind and solar power
is cheaper than fossil fuel.
Since I've been in office,
clean energy and advanced manufacturing
have brought in $470 billion
in private investments.
It's going to create thousands of jobs,
good paying jobs all across this country.
And help the environment
at the same time,
Remember, at the beginning
of this debate,
some of my
Republican colleagues are determined
to get the clean energy investments.
I said, no, we kept them all
and there's
and there's so much more to do.
We're going to do
even more to reduce the deficit.
We need to control spending.
If we're going to do that.
But we also have to raise revenue
and go
after tax cheats
and make sure everybody's
paying their fair share.
No one,
I promise
no one making
less than $400,000
a year
will pay a penny more in federal taxes.
But like most of you at home,
I know the federal tax system isn't fair.
That's why I kept my commitment again.
No one earning
less than $400,000
a year will pay a penny
more in federal taxes.
That's why last year I secured
more funding
to go more
Irish funded to go after wealthy
tax cheats.
The nonpartisan
Congressional Budget Office,
and it is nonpartisan,
says that
this bill will bring in $150 billion.
And other outside
experts expect
that it will save as much as $400 billion
because it's forcing people to pay their
fair share.
Republicans may not like it,
but I'm going to make sure
the wealthy pay their fair share.
I'm also proposed closing over a dozen
special interest tax loopholes
for big oil
crypto traders, hedge fund billionaires,
saving taxpayers billions of dollars
Republicans, Republicans defended
every single
one of these special interest loopholes.
Every single one.
But I'm going to be coming back
And with your help, I'm going to win
right now.
Catch this.
Right now,
the average
billionaire in America
pays just 8% in federal taxes.
8%.
Teachers and firefighters
pay more than that.
That's why I propose the minimum
tax for billionaires.
Republicans are against it.
But I'm going to keep fighting for it.
No billionaires
should pay less in federal taxes
than a teacher or firefighter.
Look, let me close with this.
I know bipartisanship is hard
and unity is hard,
but we can never stop trying
because a moment like this one
the ones we just faced
with the American economy
in the world, economy's
at risk of collapsing.
There's no other way.
No matter how tough our politics gets,
we see each other as not as adversaries,
but as fellow Americans
treat each other
with dignity and respect.
To join forces,
America is the sub shouted, shouting,
lower the temperature
at work together to pursue progress,
secure prosperity
and keep the promise
of America for everybody.
As I've said, my inaugural address
without unity,
there is no peace with bitterness.
And shooter and fury.
And we can never become that country.
I can honestly say
I can honestly say tonight
that I've never been more optimistic
about America's future.
We just need to remember who we are.
We are the United States of America.
And there's nothing,
nothing we can't do We do it together.
Thank you all for listening
and taking the time tonight
to listen to me.
May God bless you all
and may God protect our troops.
Thank you.